start the back road Tim Roth Demyan
Beshear Channing Tatum
Bruce turn hello Bruce Michael Madsen
front row Kurt Russell Jennifer Jason
Leigh Quentin Tarantino Samuel Jackson
and Walton Goggins I'm a gosh look very
sharp back to the first I invited you
guys in this telethon where's your
little occurred to you and Jennifer said
exit like each other and everything is
that right nice don't you owe your night
work Quentin I'm gonna start with
Quentin Quentin thank you guys for
coming and thank you for your patience I
wanna have you haven't asked a question
about Ultra Panavision obviously it's
epic and scale in terms of what it gives
you in the frame but I want to talk
about what it gives your actors in terms
of intimacy in terms of the close-ups in
terms of the relationship of one actor
the other and what that means to you as
a filmmaker to be able to shoot actors
in 70 millimeter well you've actually
kind of answered kind of your own
question a little bit
no because literally that is that the
one of the tricks that I thought about
was a the intimacy that it provides you
in empirically in close-ups
I mean I've shot a lot of close-ups of
this man right here but I've never shot
them as beautiful as I did in this movie
I mean there is a Abby I think you find
yourself taking back strokes in his eyes
so so awesome
yeah it's just the way it is you know
but one of the things that I remember
when I did the film when it get when it
was reported that I was going to do it
in this format people were actually
speculating and I guess I understand it
they were like well yeah okay that
sounds all really great but why would he
do it for a thing that just so set bound
and yeah I think that's actually just
kind of a not a very profound thinking
when it comes to a 65 millimeter that
it's basically just for shooting
travelogues or shooting mountain
sceneries or and nature and stuff I
actually felt that especially in
bringing it into Minnie's haberdashery
if the film isn't suspenseful I Corps
situation of what's going on in the
movie if that's not part of it if the
threat of violence and the the pressure
cooker situation isn't is if the
temperature isn't always getting up a
notch every every scene or so then
movies going to be boring it's not going
to work and I actually felt that uh the
big format would one it would put you in
Minnie's haberdashery you are in that
place you are amongst those characters
and I thought it would make it more
intimate when I got in close with them
but the other thing that I thought would
be very very important is there's always
two plays going on in this movie once
you're in minis in particular there's
two plays going on at all times
there's the characters that are in the
foreground of any given scene and then
there's the characters in the background
and you always have to be keeping track
especially in this scenario of where
everybody is it's like they're pieces on
a chessboard and you always have to see
it and so maybe it might be a Chris
Mannix and general Smithers who are
dealing but you're also clocking a Joe
gage at his table and you're clocking
John Ruth and Daisy at the bar and that
and that becomes important unless I
don't want it to be unless I want to cut
them out and not show it to you but you
I think that helped ration up the
tension
as things went on and for the actors
themselves I mean one of the limitations
about 70 typically is that the magazines
are very short a little wonky but it
means you have very short takes but you
are able to equip your cameras with a
lot more films so you could shoot your
actors four six and seven minutes at a
time yeah leaving longer than that I
mean the Panavision came up with a 2,000
foot mags all right we were able to like
shoot it for 11 minutes at a time which
I mean I can't even imagine doing this
material if we had to break it up and
4-minute goes we had we had to do it
like that I mean the only real big
limitation that I had as far as my
shooting was the wine scenes were very
generous with me so I didn't have to
dole out the footage in a certain way I
mean I I wasn't completely cavalier
about it but uh but I didn't really
change my shooting style for it and that
wouldn't have been the idea is it
completely changed my shooting style so
I shot the way I wanted to shoot however
the only real disadvantage I felt at the
time but then I don't feel now was we
weren't able to get a zoom lens and I
really gotten used to using a zoom lens
and the little zoom creep I've really
gotten used to that but actually there
was also kind of a nice thing to not act
to the to be forced to not use all the
tools that you've gotten used to from
time to time and be able to work in a
different way I went ask this question
to Demi and Channing and Jennifer
whoever wants to answer it you guys are
all virgins to a Quentin set rookies
what do we want to call it neophytes
when you're asking other actors first
time loser beaters practically interns
water boys describing Channing's action
great Amy yeah all those checks got
actual okay you get the trip here's my
question all about Channing answer this
one oh thanks what do you what do you
want to know from the other actors about
what to expect and what is it surprising
what is surprising about being on a
Quentin set that's different from other
movie sets um well first off this I mean
it is an actual alumni to I think being
an acquaintance film and and you really
feel that all these guys worked together
a lot and it is
unique experience to be an acquaintance
movie I can promise you and and you're
really intimidated but every single
person was so I mean Sam I did my first
movie ever with Sam and and to come full
circle like this is pretty extraordinary
I think on the first day I must have
looked so geeked out because the very
first shot was this crazy like 360 like
I'm I'm just like wide-eyed and trying
to figure out like not to screw up and
Tim goes yep yep you're about to be in
the Quentin turn well it's a kind of
Chan my god looks so big scared but it
was amazing I mean every single person
here is people that I admire greatly and
I was learning lesson every single
moment and can I just add one thing
together his buddy I told him on when we
were in rehearsal I go you do realize
you get to shoot coach Carter I am
thought about that holy [ __ ] I get to
shoot coach Carter wait although suicide
yeah yeah gosh it back now say Oh
suicide Oh
push it Channing Channing hasn't seen
the film yet sure you're kind of
spoiling it there yeah I was there for
some of it okay okay I won't ask
Jennifer and Kurt about are you guys and
I said this when we came in maybe your
mics weren't on you guys always still
sit side by side and our you side by
side throughout the show meaning when
the cameras weren't on did you try to
actually change yourselves to one
another this is probably the first time
we've ever sat like this this is very
rare co-host thinking that yeah you're
the wrong see on the wrong side anything
about it just where you know you're
starting to go with it and I say
[ __ ]
now now it's okay all's right with the
world that was weird
I almost feel like I was on a date or
something this is much more right but
Kurt after your character is no longer
among the living is that still you lying
on the floor there yeah you know I'd
spent the four and a half months chained
to Jennifer and I it felt very strange
the concept of people starting to drop
like flies and the actors that had been
there for us or no we're not going to be
there for them it just felt really weird
at outside from the fact that I had a
you know a really good ticket a
front-row seat to watch all these guys
and not have to worry about lines and
they just listen to it and watch it be
played out but I wanted to be there for
her to do whatever she needed to do look
in the movie I'm dead for whatever
period of time it is it's not three
weeks or however long it took us to do
it so for her you know if she felt like
she needed to pause on Ruth it that's
going to be different than a tummy and I
knew that by being there and by
continuing the I don't know day to day
that we all had talking to each other
and it would just was something that had
to happen until it sleep no Jennifer why
did you stop is John Rother snoring dear
guys honestly like um they had a dummy
for him it's it was 30 degrees in that
room you know so they had a full dummy
with a full face cast beautiful like you
couldn't tell from far away
I mean Walton has a lot of video now
he's like this video sat in a chair in
the in the makeup room and different
people would go up and just slap John I
just sit in like okay
honestly that video Lestat I might have
a lot of pictures of doing say that but
now that you mention it sorry but but it
can't be found on the black wig I've got
a question for Sam other actors can jump
in they wanted it knocked out inside
kicked on I just though I do want to say
one thing which is I couldn't have done
that scene without him there and that
really was three weeks of like 16-hour
days lying on a cold floor but I needed
him and he was so there for me and it's
just like but really really touched me
because as much as Daisy wanted to kill
him you know be careful what you wish
for and I would never really truly
experience that had he not been there
for me to paw and miss and feel the heat
leaving his body so that was that's only
Kurt oh we have something to announce
well please get a room
okay now I'm coming to you say I'm but
other actors you can you can answer this
Quentin's obviously very precise in his
language and when you make a Quint movie
if people don't know you say the lines
that Quentin has written yeah as an
actor when there's no room okay so my
yes yes keep the myth a lot yes outside
of your cell and write the other actors
have I mean I guess it's a good point of
debate what does that give you as an
actor when you're staying relatively
close I think other actors may be a
little bit closer to what's written in
terms of what it gives you as an actor a
lot of actors like to wing it like to
improvise when you're staying close to
the dialogue what does that benefit you
in terms of your performance I mean
there's not a lot that you need to
change and Quentin and I have
conversations about what I what I say
and I don't just willy-nilly change
things if I want to say something else
I'll go to him and discuss it with him
and we'll talk about it and he'll say
well let me hear what I wrote and I'll
say what he wrote don't let me what you
want to say and I'll say what I want to
say which is very close to what he wrote
I just want to say it another way
because I think it comes out of that
character's mouth a different way and
he'll say okay or he'll say no I'll
leave it the way I wrote it and that's
generally what happens um rest of these
[ __ ] need to say what he says
why'd you point at me points
specifically right we got on the same
wavelength and generally when I get it
it's exactly it's it's exactly what it
needs to be as characterization starts
and as we're in rehearsal there are
times when I feel like I didn't I didn't
say enough right and have enough to say
and I'll say to him could you add
something here so that I can answer that
or clarify this and Quentin will do that
but by the time the rehearsal period is
over and we get there and we're ready to
do it nothing changes except I mean the
only only big change
we had from being around the studio
table and in many Xin the studio and
being outdoors with the stagecoach was
the coal that was the one thing there
was the wild card that we didn't really
know about and all of a sudden it
changed the urgency of everything we
wanted to do especially I do it's like
okay I want to get inside that stage
goes now cuz I don't like the snow
running down my neck yeah Bruce someone
asked the same question to you about
working with Quentin as an actor you've
worked with a lot of great directors
over the course of your career what is
it special to you about working with
Quentin and how does he affect you as an
actor well in my journey I don't think
I've ever said this before but this is
the first movie I've ever done where I
felt privileged to lend a hand because
that's what you do for him he expects
everybody I don't know what percentage
he'd say but let's say casting is 20 80
percent of a movie
and he expects the people that he brings
to do what he hired them to do and not
act and be somebody else and I felt that
he asked me to come along and lend a
hand and so that's basically what it is
I mean you've got when you go to work
for him everybody on the set and we're
talking about everybody behind the
camera or division by division by
division everybody knows you have a
chance to go to the playoffs but what
you don't know is that what you're going
to end up in this one it's my first time
in an opera because the guy made an
opera and just to be a part of that not
I couldn't sit through a [ __ ] opera
but
I want to turn it over some audience
questions some press questions we'll try
to move it along I'll go here and be
sure to include our back row we got a
lot of people here so the shorter the
better so we can get to as many as
possible hang on one sec we have my
question for Quentin as a filmmaker
you're always more interested in the
past whether it's historical periods or
cinematic styles I just wonder if you
ever have a hankering or how you think
you'd tackle it if you looked in the
other direction not necessarily making a
film set in the future but you know
adapting your style away from westerns
and the cold John as we know you fall
that's you actually that's a really
interesting idea I don't think anyone's
ever proposed it exactly the way you
propose it to me everyone always talks
about the science fiction genre in
particular which always makes me think
about people in spaceships and that's
not and I can appreciate that but that's
not really um where I think my my
dramatist aspect lies out of the way
you've posted before I don't think I've
ever thought about it as far as like
dealing with a future society like ours
but what would that and what would that
entail and what would it mean to jump
you know 20 years or 50 years or 100
years in the future and Lily look at it
from that point of view I've never
really thought about that before but
that I'm as a profound thought I have to
admit look let me ask you a corollary of
that just making a period film allow you
the ability to comment on the present in
ways that a present-day film doesn't
yeah well I think you there's a
definitely case where if you tried to
when you try to when you try to deal I'm
not saying it's a bad thing to do but
when you try to deal with present themes
in the present uh you know your that is
what you're doing yeah that is the
railroad you're building and that's
where and that's where that train is
going and that can actually be fantastic
we can all point at the versions in
cinema history that has been profound um
I do like putting scenario first I do
like putting story first and I actually
like masking whatever I want to say in
the guise of genre
I can say it with my left hand and then
deal with the right hand with the genre
dictates however in that in this
instance per se or in particular I guess
what I meant is it's one of the benefits
of the western genre I think there's no
weather genre that has dealt that deals
with America better in its in a subjects
away than the Western is being made in
the in the different decades ie like the
50s westerns very much a put forth an
Eisenhower idea of America and an
American exceptionalism aspect of it
where the westerns of the 70s were very
cynical about America and the one of the
you know um it was a drag that that
first draft of the script got out when
it did however as we were making this
movie was during that last year and a
half where many of the themes that we
were dealing with we were watching on
television when we got home and we would
come to the set and we would talk about
them the one good thing about the script
getting out there as soon as I'm on
record for having written this before
all this [ __ ] started popping off in the
last year and a half ah next question
let's go little thing about that too is
that a lot earlier in that other script
yeah I got about that I mentioned it to
somebody else yeah I did
we'll go here wait for your microphone
again spread the love around I'm gonna
Mario from Mexico I would like to ask
with the Mexican fella are there today
course of course you know from Mexico
yeah
can you talk at you you're famous in
Mexico - Splore - the bones the
characters and can you phone for
training can you talk about how much fun
do you have in the set and how much do
you were allowed to do it in your
character um we were making coca leaves
yeah hello Trump um you know I just had
the best seat in the house how seats you
know from day one meeting this guy right
here and uh being being being a big fan
of his films forever it was just great
to see how you know to see him in action
and see him how he does what he does and
then I remember having this first table
reading with all these beautiful actors
reading those lines that was for me you
know a beautiful ride and I still have
the best seat in the house you know I'm
just having a lot of fun and you need a
crazy director a free director director
that's not afraid of taking risks in
order to help you get you know where you
want to go so that's pretty much what we
did good question I'm gonna go here go
ahead yep wait for the mic this is for
Michael and Tim you guys have been with
Quentin from the very beginning so
what's a venn and now situation for mr.
Cantina Michael's ready well at least we
didn't get stuck together this time Tim
and I embraced each other on the set of
Reservoir Dogs and we had both so much
blood on our bodies that we were stuck
together
and we were stuck together like more
than we wanted to be it was like the hug
that lasted a little too long and and
they actually had to use a a gay a
garden hose to uh to separate us yeah
so we was good at our deaths this time
that we were on opposite sides of the
room but I I enjoyed so much watching
Tim and watching him find his character
I think back in the dog days I was young
man and I was very naive I didn't know
what the hell I was doing not that I do
now but I enjoyed watching Tim and I
enjoyed watching him much more than I
would have remembered from the years
before that's what change for me is I
grew to appreciate and watch him how
wonderful he is you know as a friend
also Tim come on buddy
all right he's all right
no it's been a trip it's been a trip it
was kind of a weird sensation to be the
old school the old the old boys come in
because Sam's been around around as much
as I have around Quentin but but so I've
been I have had a long break I know I
didn't make it make it back in
since sort of forums and public
functions so for us it's kind of a right
sport rooms full run sorry um but um so
I didn't know the new new kind of
version of what of how he filmed and the
kind of atmosphere that on set that he
he's encouraged and developed it was
brand new for me so it's almost in a
sense like coming to Quentin fresh again
it was wonderful
Quentin are you writing for specific
actors for most of the roles some of the
roles yeah in this case yeah uh
everybody here that I'd work with before
I wrote for them in that case the the
wild cards were a Dahmer goo and Bob and
Joey next question let's go here go
ahead yep
wait for the mic my question is for
Walton
what's the over-under on whether your
character in hateful eight is related to
your character and Django again what's
the over/under weather what's over and
under and whether or not your character
in Django is related to your character
in hateful eight uh Wow yeah yeah maybe
that's yeah that day that's his uncle or
something like that yeah yeah what a
shitty family have the worst family in
America merica The Borgias of America
you said something you said something
earlier that was so interesting to me
you talked about Quentin and people talk
about Quinn's dialogue and from but from
an actor's perspective but you have to
understand this is this is like finding
like gold in a river this is like
panning for gold like in the gold rush
days in California when you come across
this when you get this invitation and it
was one day in particular this is a
great story it was one day in particular
where I read this stuff like 300 times
we all do and Quentin said at the
outside he said you need to know these
words as every actor up here does not
just so that you can be ready at any
given moment to kind of go wherever it
is in story but so that you can give
this man a hundred different versions if
that's what he needs in order to reaches
his vision right and that's just kind of
what I do that's how I look at it and
there was one day in particular work
when gave me a monologue like and it was
just like a page and I've spent 14 years
in television learned 10 pages for me
like in an hour is no problem but this
is Quentin Tarantino dialogue and and it
started off in the morning I got it
first thing as soon as I got there right
after our coffee like like our Co we
have a coffee club in the morning and so
and so I'm sitting there man I'm having
the best [ __ ] day I know 150 pages of
this grant know everybody's [ __ ] and
then I get this this thing it's like
from Coco who just kind of comes up says
hello hey Quentin wants you to say this
later on today and it's like like like
here right it's the whole thing and it
just like freaked me out and I get
brought me down it was like because it's
like oh [ __ ] really now I got to get up
from the coffee and I start walking
around and and people see that I'm
freaking out a little bit
and temp temp says uh Haman what's wrong
what's wrong with you I said look I got
it this right here I got this today I
got this today so you got that man no I
don't I don't [ __ ] have this and they
Kurt like literally an hour later and
I'm and I'm just pacing around back and
forth and Kurt said hey MELAS what's
wrong with you guys
this man this and he said you you got
this I said no I [ __ ] don't
and then the same with Sam Sam said
something - because I just walk in I
pace and then that night it all came
down to I was the last thing that we
shot and it was with me and Bruce and
we're sitting there in the chair and
even then I'm just [ __ ] freaking out
and Quinton just looks at me he says you
got this made you want red wine with
rolling out this is for Quentin um in a
sense right yeah I think in a sense you
created your own genre your movies are
powerful and thought-provoking and
Austin dancing on the edge of being
politically correct what are your
thoughts on being politically correct in
today's society um I don't have much
thought on that uh uh other than just
kind of I guess in a conversation like
the way you're having it right now the
way you're asking for it it's me right
now or I guess I just I just don't think
about it that way I mean um uh it isn't
a one can be inclined to say oh if this
political correctness I don't have time
for that but also the you know but in in
polite society there is such a thing as
a sensitivity to some issues as time has
gone on and there was a time that we
weren't politically correct at all and
we all wince at moments when we look
past and we see that I don't really know
what the answer is as far as that as far
as that is concerned however me as an
artist I don't really think about it at
all it actually is not my job to think
about that
especially in terms of with me as a
writer in particularly as I mean I also
as a filmmaker
I'm not worried about the filmmaking
part because if I've written it that's
what I'm going to do but in particularly
as a writer it is my job to to ignore
social critics or the response that
social critics might have when it comes
to the opinions of my characters the way
they talk or anything that can happen to
them I mean we can talk about exactly we
can talk about the race stuff which we
actually talk but I'm sure somebody some
people here sitting in the room might be
uncomfortable about the violence that is
handed out to Jennifer's character and
actually I'm playing with that in the
course of the movie when she gets that
cracked in the head by John Ruth at the
beginning of the movie that is mentis
into shockwave out through the audience
and it and you're meant to think you're
not Nestle mental like Dahmer goo in
that moment but you are meant to think
that John Ruth is a brutal bastard at
that moment because that does seem like
a rather overreaction to what she to
what she did and what she said now time
goes on and you see how you feel about
the characters but it's meant to do that
um but there is this aspect of the way
this story works in general is I have
trapped eight people actually nine
people if you include OB he's not part
of the hateful ache is not hateful all
right relate and OB alright would be the
UM Gabby Hayes yeah but the thing is
though uh but the way the story works
part of the actual that tension that
we're talking about the pressure cooker
that we're talking about and because of
you know where I'm coming from you know
in that vaguely esque Peckinpah ask away
to some degree or another is anything
can happen to these guys anything can
happen to these characters any piece
about rages violence could happen to
them and there is and I paint in a
system where there aren't color book
lines I can cross those lines you know
the way the way graphic novels I don't
mean graphic novels as in a comic book
but the way novels that deal with
violence kind of almost seem to go
anywhere in a way that movies aren't
allowed to
and so in that scenario what I'm going
to make it that oh seven of these
characters anything can happen to them
but when it comes to this eight
character I have to protect her because
she's a woman and they can't have the
Destiny that it can happen to any of
these other characters no that goes
against the entire story I'm not going
to think like that and when I think of I
guess a bit basically an artistic hero
in that you know predecessor when it
comes to that I I think if somebody like
Ken Russell who was uh you know who was
raked over the coals by the press in
England constantly for the boundaries he
pushed and he said you know do they look
do they let these people get you down
because I don't think about them I can't
think about them it's my job not to
think about them because I believe in
what I'm doing a hundred percent and I
am doing what I'm doing if you don't
like it don't go see it well wait and
thank you guys
you